ποιο άσιμος να μαγαητήης την κύπρο ρα είναι ένας μιστώς σοβαρός ίσως να παίρνει και
ένα μιστώ ενώς πιλότου άρα γιατί να θεωρούμε ότι δεν μπορεί να επιβιώσεια νμάλες καλιτέχνεις
αμαθέλουμετα πολλά δεν μπορούμε να επιβιώσουμε αλλά υ πραγματικό ότι να το νέρωτικότη μπορεί κεφάλειο
γυροβίζουν θα το σκεφτό τανο σταύρος κασταντίνουτάξει πουβαίνεται λίγο ξένο για μέ να η ροβίζουν
με τη φιλοσοφία για τη μεοτροπία αλλά ποτέ μιλές ποτέ μέρα ίσως σίγουρα ελληνικό τραγούδι
γιατί ανμεβάλεις να πει ξέρω εβάλεις να πό ξέρω το μόνο που μπορώ αψει πο
ίω σίνε τον κάπιο παίρένα ωραίο ελληνικό στοίχο μεμε να χιθείμε να πάκραουν αυτό τραγούδι
να εξιστορικάτυρα παιδί μου δεν ξέρω δεν ξέρω ότη μπορείναι προτάσει ποτε να εκπροσπήει όχι
θέλω να πάμε πίσω λίγο σταρι άλη της σήμερα ο σταύρος μετα από τόσα χρόνια
που κιέρδησε σε ναριάληται πώς τα βλέπειη θεωρίσει ότι σήμερα βγαινούν αρκετά κάθε χρόνο μ
εκτός τα τελευταία χρόνια επυπάρχει ένα διάλημα από ν ατά θεωρείς ότι υπάρχει υπάρχουν τα
φοντα για τους νικητές και όχι μόνο να εξελιχθούν μετά ήαπλαγίνονται για να γίνομε εγώ
με τις συπλοσοφίας της εξής καταρχεή μιλάσμενα άνθρωπο οποίος πήγε σε να παιχνί διάρα έχω
την εμπιρία και το βίοαπό ένα τηλεπαιχνίτη και πολο πόσο μάλλον στα ξεκινήματα του που
η αλήθεια εί ήταν διαφορετική η αντιμετώπιση τότε θεωρώ ότι δεν υπάρχει άλλος τρόπος υπάρχει
υπάρχει το δύο γιασκος πέτε σήμερα και τα τελευταία λίγα χρόνια που υπάρχουν τας όσο
αλμύτια υπάρχει τον τίκτο που υπάρχουν πάρα πολλές εφαρμογιές που φάνικε και όλας ότι κάποιοι
καναγκαριέρα μέσα από αυτά γιατί κάποι κατάφεραν κάποιοι να τους δούν ποκή ναι ναι ναι
στην ουσία υ προβολύ είναι παρόλα αυτά ότι προβολήι